how you doing in a new experience so you
have you don't know how you're doing
because you've never experienced it I
have a lot of people that depend on me
all my supervisors said doc it's time
you man up so I'm trying to man up is
there such thing as man enough in a
situation like this you're asking me
that yes and you know there is you I am
a crybaby
I am I blame it on my heritage mm-hmm I
can cry talking about crying so I will
would be crying through the whole thing
and I saw I can't stop it so I can't do
that and decisions I can't make them
right now I just might lost my wife you
can't do that you can't use this as an
excuse okay hmm
so Manning up would be you know not get
over it but face it take over it what's
in that pink box well I've never done
ashes of my life and that's what she
wanted and then she wants me to do it
and put the same thing gets put on a
fireplace or something so yeah this is
the most more of it stuff brah
oh it's like it's like morbid right for
her final wishes what if she want you to
do with those ashes
well she said scatter some leave some on
the fireplace of course when I go to
heaven she wants me in the box with her
not like will I like you know I was
gonna do all the scattering I did you
know blah blah blah and then I looked at
it thought I'm not gonna throw you like
away I just throw you away it started
over and I can't do that so right now I
like them it can't be more of it I don't
you know I haven't gotten past the place
where I'm still putting a pillow where
she was and covering it up like the
jailhouse escape mm-hmm right I mean it
and then I wake up will like sear and it
doesn't register than any juror I'm
still there